the Joe Rogan experience see this
resonates with everybody delicious pasta
resonates with everybody that's why so
many women were mad when Adele lost all
that weight yes like no [ __ ] I don't
want to give up on this [ __ ] pasta
yeah I was with you when you were big
yeah see there's a new photo of her yeah
no I saw it this morning she first thing
I knew the flitter Li the first thing
that I thought of the second my eyes
laid on that picture I'm like this is
gonna be crazy because people are going
to say in these comments that she's
beautiful and that's going to be
hilarious because you're basically
saying that she wasn't beautiful before
by saying that she's beautiful now in a
weird way they're sort of insinuated and
and I I didn't even realize until two
hours or an hour later after I had woken
up that it became like this like news
story so it's just funny to me because
like it's like is their voice the same
right because that's what matters well
it's it's funny in that why wouldn't you
[Music]
want to applaud someone who did
something that's really difficult to do
and is now healthier yeah if you are an
Adele fan wouldn't you want her to be
healthier wouldn't you I mean you want
her to be able to keep singing for
longer right you love her you wanted to
be healthier you don't want her to get
one of the main things they found in New
York City about people that caught covet
19 that was a real problem was obesity
big problem she was at one point in time
much larger and now she's like really
slim and people are mad and saying this
is what they're saying I don't want her
to be applauded for losing weight as if
it's some some to some wording like this
like that I don't want to adhere to
these beauty standards that she's better
looking because she lost weight but she
is yeah and you know that the only
reason why anybody would want to fight
against that when so many people
overwhelmingly think she looks better is
because they don't want to look at
themselves
it's that simple they don't want to
change and they want you to just they're
trying to bully you in deciding they're
beautiful if they're 210 pounds yeah
that's that's really what it is it's
like we're you know we're redefining
beauty standards you can't do that right
you can't decide that the way you look
is what everybody should like that's
crazy you can't do that and if people
have decided worldwide that fitter
healthier bodies are more attractive
that's just what it is yeah that's what
you can it's not redefining beauty
standards the beauty standards come from
what people are attracted to yeah it's
not fair
you're right it's not fair a lot of [ __ ]
and life's not fair yeah that's just how
it is
yeah if you choose to stay big that is
your choice I know it's a difficult
choice to try to move your your body
down and lose weight and get healthy we
really talked about that we were just
talking about it but you can't say that
it's unattractive when someone has a
good body because it is so if someone
has a better body than they used to have
it looks better so that's what a beauty
standard is this is what people are
attracted to when it comes to bodies
they're attracted to fit bodies that's
not a that's not a shame that's not a
bad thing like the idea that this is
somehow or another that's something we
need to avoid and putting undue pressure
on people it's nonsense
it looks great if it's pressure on you
because other people look great well
what do you do with that pressure do you
decide to be better better yourself take
care yourself better do you decide you
decide that it's not worth as much to
you to worry about what your body looks
like and you're more concentrated on
maybe art or whatever the [ __ ] else
that's fine too but you can't be mad at
people that put a lot of energy in that
direction and look better right because
she looks better it's not a bad thing
and isn't saying that everybody's body
is beautiful no matter what it doesn't
that make it like worse for the people
with ugly faces you know what I mean
because like then they're more part of
just a smaller group like if there's
some lady that has like her eyes are on
like the side of her head but just an a
bangin body right she still gets action
I guess no problem at all yeah of course
she's hot well dude men don't care that
much where you're its beauty standards
of just what Pete what are people
attracted to it's and people are
generally attracted to people that are
healthier that's just a physical thing
that's a part of and we're only talking
about attractive like sexual attraction
right we're not saying you know if
you're twenty or thirty pounds
overweight like you look horrible I
don't want to look at you like I have a
lot of friends that are fat but it is
what it is it's just it is what it is
mm-hmm and maybe they'll find somebody
that's into that but you can't like
decide that people gonna change what
they're attracted to that's silly
you can't do that like they are
attracted to people that put out more
effort they're attracted to people that
have the strength to get up at six
o'clock in the morning go to the gym
before work there's something really hot
about that it's attractive yeah it's
attractive someone who takes care of
themselves it is it just is now it might
not be to you but that's why the world's
beautiful because we can all have
different things that we like and
different things we don't like but when
a giant chunk of people are into this
one thing like nice bodies it doesn't
mean that it's all shallow or terrible
or it's somehow another demeaning to
people that don't adhere to those
standards know it's a competition
there's a sort of a physical
physiological competition between males
and females in terms of like trying to
be attractive and that's one of the
things they do they make their body look
better another thing they do is dress
nice they wear jewelry they do stuff to
make themselves look better the idea
that making your body look better is
somehow or another this is a bad
standard to adhere to when you take your
big body that you're not taking care of
and you wrap it up and all this crazy
clothes and all these ribbons and bows
and you show your bare midriff because
you're brave and you get your big old
ass these jeans like yeah it still looks
pretty good don't get me wrong still
look great honestly I thought Adele I
thought Adele looked a little I thought
she looked cuter a little bit thicker
now she little sort of looks I mean
granted she looks healthier but she
looks a little bit
more just basic you know and I mean sort
of just like every all the other pop
stars well in every movie where there's
a guy was kind of a [ __ ] up who's gonna
get in trouble it's a guy who's built
like you with a woman it was like 250
pounds and she tells him what to do so
maybe it's like a thing like that's like
when it doesn't hasn't David Spade
played a character like that was like
he's got a big wife or a big girl
right there's always a few of those
think so maybe that's your thing maybe
like to deal with channel how shallow
how yeah yeah dude maybe that's your
thing is but big ones you're like I'm
big
so when Adele was big you like yes
control me hold me down maybe I don't
know I want to know about her boys
sounds like what if she sounds horrible
now cuz like she had that operatic right
yeah our full powerful voice I was
having a conversation with a buddy who
told me like to have a ball gag put in
his mouth it's like really like what
people are into him saying you know I'm
not saying that people can't be into big
girls
there's a lot of people into big girls
but a lot of people are into everything
you know but that's okay too
like a lot of people are into weird
stuff you gotta try out different things
I think if you can if you can get it
it's fun
[Applause]